[Music]
welcome to this special edition of
Hannity the Trump agenda
I'm Jeanine Pirro in tonight for Shawn
president Trump just moments ago wrapped
up a speaking engagement at the rally
for Luther strange in Huntsville Alabama
at the rally President Trump explained
why he's supporting strange in the
primary runoff election taking place on
Tuesday during that rally President
Trump
touched on a number of big issues
including putting America first take a
look I will always defend America's
interest above all US I'm here for you
I'm not here for global interests we're
not here for the rest of the globe and
we want to treat the rest of the globe
right and you know when I say America
first everywhere saying gee and I never
liked it from the standpoint that if
you're in another country you want your
country to be first by the leader why so
nobody really understood for years
they've said America first although I'm
the one that really means it there's a
big difference
President Trump also explained how the
border wall is coming and soon here's
what he said about that by the way the
wall is happening folks okay believe me
so you need to have a great wall but it
has to be has to be see-through we are
now looking at samples we have four
samples that have already been built
general right they've been built and
we're looking at different samples
already of see through walls we are
going to have as much wall as we need
you don't need it all the way you know
you have 2,000 miles you don't need it
because you have a lot of natural
barriers etc somebody said well what are
you gonna do you're gonna build that
wall in the middle of the river are you
gonna but that nobody can go in are you
gonna build that wall on the mountain
see if you don't need the one that you
have a mountain which is a wall but
we're gonna build the wall it's coming
along great another topic the president
focused on tonight was the GOP failing
to repeal Obamacare with Obamacare I've
been listening for seven years as many
of these people now Richard kept voting
against it but many of these people kept
saying repeal and replace repeal and
replace then they finally have now they
didn't care nobody cared because at a
president that wasn't gonna sign it and
they didn't have the Senate so it didn't
matter so it didn't take much courage so
they were getting all these great votes
you know like I think they voted what 61
times like 61 times to repeal or replace
they finally get a president who will
sign the legislation and they don't have
the guts to vote for it okay they don't
have the guts the president also spoke
about how he wants to get tax reform
done immediately we're moving quickly to
pass a massive tax cut and
simplification for the middle class we
want new tax returns we want
simplification we want reform and you
know what we really want we want massive
tax cuts that's what we're doing for
business that's what we're doing for the
middle class
if we want to restore American
prosperity we need tax reform that is
pro-growth pro-jobs pro worker
pro-family and pro-american and North
Korea's dictator Kim Jong on got a
warning from the president we can't have
madmen out there shooting rockets all
over the place Rocketman should have
been handled a long time ago he should
have been handled a long time ago by
Clinton I won't mention the Republicans
right but by Obama why why did this you
know this is a different this is a
different time this should have been
handled eight years ago
and four years ago and honestly and 15
years ago and 20 years ago and 25 years
ago
this shouldn't be handled now but I'm
gonna handle it
little Rocketman we're going to do it
because we really have no choice he may
be smart he may be strategic and he may
be totally crazy but you know what no
matter what he is we're gonna handle it
folks believe me and joining us now with
reaction on the president's remarks is
Salem nationally syndicated radio host
Larry elder America first action-packed
spokesman and senior advisor former
Milwaukee County Sheriff David Clarke an
American Conservative Union chair match
slap bourree good evening gentlemen
man I'm going to go to you first why get
involved in a primary election yeah you
know judge I was the political director
for President Bush and you should be
very careful about weighing into these
primary fights because what's
interesting in Alabama is most of the
people you would consider the Trump
voters our line would judge more but yet
you're here you have Donald Trump coming
in and endorsing Luthor strange who
quite honestly has been a very reliable
vote for the Trump agenda so it's a very
tricky situation and I tell you Tuesday
I can't predict what's going to happen
all right
David Clark I mean did the president
a good argument for voting for Luther
over judge Roy Moore well I think he's
gonna win either way here I think
whatever happens hold on
David you think that Luther strange is
gonna win because he's the underdog
right now no I'm not call him
I'm not calling out who's gonna win I
said that the president will win either
way
whoever wins on Tuesday I think there'll
be a reliable Trump agenda supporter so
you know this is the politics of primary
you can get a little sticky at times and
get a little uncomfortable but he's
gonna the president's gonna come out of
a winner either way no matter who wins
the primer what did the president make a
good argument David for supporting or
having people vote for Luther strange
over Roy Moore sure he did because
basically what he did what I heard is he
blasted the GOP as a body look the
Congress as a body is dysfunctional
trying to get them to work on anything
together it's like trying to herd cats
so what he's trying to do really is
mobilize and energize the people the
public all across America to start to
put the pressure on the GOP to get his
agenda passed and to get it under way
and right now you know it seems to be
stuck in neutral because of this
dysfunctional Congress and basically the
GOP is in charge so it falls in their
lap all right Larry what do you think
about this I mean about the president
getting involved in this primary race
and you know when you think about it I
mean he's got a lot on the line if you
know with Luther wins it's good for him
he came in and saved the underdog and he
goes back to you know the legislature a
strong person if Luther doesn't win he
goes back looking to get help looking
and looking to get both health care and
tax reform looking weak well I was
surprised he got involved in this race
too you know
Huntsville Alabama is my mom's hometown
so I was pleased to see him but I was
surprised he got involved in this race
if he doesn't doesn't win he loses
prestige people are gonna think that
it's okay to defy Trump on the other
hand if he pulls this out and Luther is
estranged is the underdog I suggest that
the president has a lot more clout than
people think look his poll numbers are
up he come
off this boffo United Nations speech he
still hasn't backed down from all his
promises including the wall so this gave
him an extraordinary opportunity to to
restate his presidency and and to talked
about what he wants to do in the future
this is not a guy who's afraid of
getting impeached I'll tell you that
well do you know when when we talk about
him as an establishment candidate this
Luther strange you know Mitch
McConnell's PAC Matt gave him nine
million dollars yeah and this is
becoming an increasing problem I think
it's one of the reasons why Luther
strange has struggled so badly you know
judge it's gonna come as no surprise to
you that if you're a candidate running
out there in America and you are tied to
the GOP Washington establishment it is
not a positive and I'm surprised at that
PAC spent that money directly in the
race I think it's one of the impacts I
think Luther Strange is having trouble
making the case that he is his own man
something that judged more has
demonstrated throughout his career I
tell you the one thing I get for the
president here judges he's he's
rewarding his friend and Luther strange
has been a reliable vote for him but he
is right to take on this Congress seven
and a half years of talking about
Obamacare and watching these senators
weasel out of it I'd think they're I
think people across across this country
it's pitchfork time well it is when you
have the Oval and then the Senate and
and Congress David Clarke I mean you
know to not get anything done to me is a
signal that the establishment is looking
to get rid of Donald Trump they are not
looking to support him well look that's
precisely what's happening right now
there are people who are two-faced about
this I'm talking about the GOP we know
the Dems stand on this thing but within
the GOP in public they might talk about
how they're for tax reform a
market-based healthcare system
infrastructure rebuilding law and order
those sorts of things but they're really
not inside they're really not pushing
and that's what the president needs he
needs people to help push this agenda
through the Congress and they're just
not providing the heavy lifting that
they need to do well all right you know
what Larry elder I want to move on a
little bit about the speech what did you
think of the news for the new title
little Rokit
man kim jeong-hoon has been demoted he
used to be rocket man now he's little
rocket man yeah look other nation
national leaders have referred to him as
rocket man Donald Trump says and all of
a sudden Donald Trump's a war monger
there was a cover story in the Economist
which is a British newspaper 2006 with
khun kim jeong-hoon on it calling him
rocket man nobody said anything Donald
Trump says it now all of a sudden he's
irresponsible and he's a war monger
double standard
it's just that Donald Trump derangement
syndrome that we've been talking about
ever since he became president he can't
he can't do anything right but I'll tell
you what Matt what I think he did right
was give an incredibly strong speech at
the UN letting everyone know you know
what it's okay if you want to support
your country I'm gonna support mine not
to the detriment of yours unless you're
coming out to hurt me I mean I thought
this speech was phenomenal he explained
it so well what was great about it for
Donald Trump he's so good at
communicating in quick little bursts but
he actually gave us a philosophical
understanding of what it means to stand
up for a sovereign country with
sovereignty means and he also talked
about why communism and socialism
continues to fail around the globe and
let me tell you judge when he takes on
Cuba and North Korea in Iran I'm gonna
stand up and Cheer every time well Cuba
North Korea Iran and David Venezuela as
well saying you know though it wasn't a
problem I don't have the quote exactly
right was it a problem where the
socialism or the it were the
implementation it was it's just a
problem with socialism yeah it's been a
matter of fact what he said the words of
the effect that it was implemented
proper properly socialism that is the
problem it was a fantastic speech and
every time he gets on the world stage
like that he did it when he was over in
Warsaw I hear people even who might not
care about him say that's one of the
best speeches they ever heard because
he's a great communicator but I was real
pleased to see him stand up in that well
at the UN and proudly talk about what
America has accomplished what America is
about that we're here to work with
people that want to work with us and
it's it's a two-way street but I'll tell
you what every time he gets in that
world stage
the leadership that this guy exhibits
and I say that affectionately the
presidents it's astounding but now we
have America that's going to be front
and center in terms of working with the
world but again America comes first I
like that all right Larry elder finally
in terms of a tax reform health care
what do you think is going to happen
this week
well as you heard it from the speech
Trump hasn't given up and I thought I
heard some implied pressure on the
Republican senator from Alaska who voted
against the last repeal replacement bill
who hasn't decided yet not Donald Trump
so he hasn't given up
and by the way judge did you notice they
that the time at his background the
white and red stripes and the white and
red stripes in the background you think
that was a coincidence I don't think so
that the president is is a he's
brilliant he's a show man he gets it he
gets it on so many levels but it'll be
very interesting to see what happens in
the next week or two
big impact on 2018 anyway thank you
gentlemen for being with us tonight